en este vídeo haremos algunos ejemplos
para graficar rectas usando las
coordenadas de algún punto y la
pendiente recuerden que la pendiente m
es igual a 10 2 - y 1 / x 2 menos x1
porque la recta pasa por los puntos
x 1,1 y x 2,2 y una forma de ver a la
pendiente es como el cambio en g / el
cambio en x ese pequeño triángulo
simboliza cambio y eso es igual a la
elevación entre la longitud entonces una
vez que conocemos un punto de la recta y
la pendiente para mí la pendiente sería
cómo conocer la dirección para llegar al
siguiente punto e incluso podemos
conocer las coordenadas de ese nuevo
punto y hasta podemos sacar la ecuación
de esa recta si es que la necesitamos
entonces vamos a ver en el inciso a
supongamos que tenemos una recta que
pasa por el punto 1,2 y que tiene una
pendiente
3 ok entonces este es el punto 12 y
sabemos que tiene una pendiente igual a
este es el inciso a entonces
si esta recta tiene una pendiente de 3
bueno lo primero que yo hago es escribir
la pendiente como fracción en este caso
la voy a escribir como 3 entre 1 y miren
el 3 en el numerador nos dice que la
pendiente sube o se eleva 3 unidades y
como es positiva eso significa que va
hacia arriba y luego el denominador que
en este caso es 1 positivo ese sería el
cambio en x por lo tanto la pendiente
nos dice que a partir del punto que
conocemos
vamos a subir 3 unidades y nos moveremos
una unidad hacia la derecha así
obtendremos el siguiente punto con el
que podremos dibujar la recta
entonces como nos encontramos en la
coordenada
2 para ir hacia arriba necesitamos subir
3 unidades
entonces subimos 3 4 5 y 5 y después nos
dice ok sube 3 unidades pero también
muévete una unidad hacia la derecha
entonces como el primer punto se
encuentra en uno positivo el segundo
punto se encuentra en 2 así que las
coordenadas del punto original son 12 y
ahora ya conocemos las coordenadas del
segundo punto que son 25 y bueno ahora
simplemente dibujamos nuestra recta pero
no creo que pase por el origen entonces
la mejor forma de graficar la es que
bueno si nos movimos tres unidades hacia
arriba y una hacia la derecha eso sería
lo mismo que si decimos lo contrario es
decir tres unidades hacia abajo y una
unidad hacia la izquierda entonces
tres unidades llegamos a menos uno y
después uno hacia la izquierda nos deja
en x igual a cero y así es como podemos
graficar nuestra recta y recuerden que
tiene una pendiente positiva ya sabíamos
que va de izquierda a derecha ok ahora
hagamos el otro ejemplo aquí nos piden
graficar la recta que pasa por el punto
menos 2,1 entonces menos uno menos dos
hacia la izquierda y después una unidad
hacia arriba ok y nos dicen que tiene
una pendiente igual a menos dos tercios
y bueno no importa a quien le asignen el
signo negativo lo podemos poner en el
numerador o en el denominador de
cualquier forma obtendrán la misma
gráfica entonces en mi caso como el
numerador es menos 2
eso significa que tengo que ir hacia
abajo 2 unidades porque nos dicen que el
cambio en g es negativo y eso significa
que la pendiente d
hace dos unidades y por otro lado como
el denominador es positivo eso significa
que nos movemos tres unidades hacia la
derecha ok y si somos cuidadosos podemos
simplemente contar los espacios entonces
las coordenadas del primer punto son
menos 2,1 y podemos ver la altura como
si nos encontráramos al nivel del mar
por ejemplo o en algún piso supongamos
que ahí tenemos la coordenada ye igual a
1 y después nos dicen que tenemos que
bajar dos unidades entonces es como si
tuviéramos que bajar dos pisos tal vez
nos encontrábamos en el primer piso de
algo y si bajamos un nivel nos
encontramos al nivel del piso pero
después bajamos otro nivel y ahí nos
encontramos en -1 entonces bajamos dos
unidades y ahora nos dicen que tenemos
que movernos tres unidades hacia la
derecha una unidad dos y finalmente
llegamos a la coordenada donde
y si es igual a 1 positivo este es
nuestro punto entonces al bajar dos
unidades llegamos a la coordenada de
igual a menos 1 y al agregar a la
coordenada x una dos tres unidades
llegamos a la coordenada x igual a uno
positivo ok y ahora simplemente
conectamos los puntos esta es nuestra
gráfica y miren definitivamente no pasa
por el origen porque cruza un poquito
por abajo más o menos así
entonces si ya conocen un punto de la
recta y la pendiente analicen la
pendiente escriban la como una fracción
si no es fraccionaria como en el primer
ejemplo y bueno simplemente piensen en
moverse por la gráfica como si fueran
direcciones y también si ustedes quieren
incluso pueden agregar más puntos espero
que les sirva